the jurgen experience apl
that place felix you like felix has an
outside oh they do
oh that's wonderful they're whole
outside it's fantastic that's awesome
maybe i'll go there tonight they have a
next-door restaurant that had this whole
outside area they checked out over there
in the desert when you go to a
restaurant it does you eat the food you
like chewing it you're like what the
[ __ ] is this
i don't know what goes on i go to like
seafood restaurants after i start
chewing something i'm like i don't even
know what this
is i've no i there's one good one called
pacifica which is really good
but there's a lot of restaurants out
there in the desert where you go
something's wrong
so you just decided to go out there did
you previously have experience with toms
no but i was in a car and then the
people the riots started
so i i was in a car and the riot started
and i literally
instead of going back to my house
because i live right off sunset an
apartment right off sunset
instead of going back i just got on the
10 east that's
never even been out there i just said i
put the clothes on my back
i said not instead of getting under 10
east
what am i gonna go i look like a cop i
look like a guy that should be burned
alive
for every sin that this country has
committed right
no one would care my own parents would
be like he probably did something
right to deserve that so i'm like i'm
getting the [ __ ] out of here because
i get lit up immediately um so i just
started driving under 10 east i got an
airbnb i took some dude i'm like hey can
i you know it was a nice everybody
and i just got out there and i'm like i
[ __ ] love it out here it's just
nice it's just quiet i know people have
like vacation spots
of course and then i just said to myself
i'm like if la's not going to be if i'm
not at the store
and i'm not doing anything i can drive
in to do podcasts
i can easily drive in how long did it
take you to get here
uh under two oh that's not bad about two
and it's like a san diego
all the traffic is ventura freeway have
you ever thought about living down there
like la jolla
no no two i'm not a surfer
you know what i mean can't be a servant
i'm not here i came here to do stand-up
comedy
i came here to create things um i didn't
come here to
be a surfer i didn't come here to do
yoga i didn't come here to join a cult
i didn't come here to do any of that i'm
an east coast guy like east coast is
where i was born and raised like
which makes sense that you're in the
palm desert yeah because it should well
what are you gonna do i'm not i can't go
move back to new york get shot in the
face so i'm staying there until december
to the holidays and then i'll figure out
you know who knows we'll see what's
happening in the world
the violence rate in new york right now
is awesome it's a little too much
it's a little too much so crazy it's a
lot and
listen how are they going to turn that
back it'll be turn around dude in five
years
everything it's a cycle it'll it'll
bottom out a little bit or
or be done forever becomes bosnia it'll
be a cycle dude in five years a bunch of
rich kids will move in there just like
they moved in there in 2009
they'll start doing alternative comedy
dressing like [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] like flappers yeah
they'll start tripping you know
and they'll just and and that'll be the
resurgence of the city they'll
they'll they'll they'll open a bunch of
new coffee houses in
what used to be homeless shelters and
it'll just and it's just a cycle
but what needs to happen now there's
gonna be a lot of pain yeah there's
gonna be a lot of displacement of people
and then i think this could be the route
to the city getting cool again
to maybe younger artistic people coming
in architects doing cool [ __ ]
reimagining public spaces you know new
york needs to get shaken out of its tree
a little bit and so does la that's
what's happening
right i just don't want to be here for
it like maybe it'll get dirty and
dangerous again
it's going to get to the point where
maybe everything won't suck times square
will be like time square
yeah and people that move to new york
will will they'll be
you know listen if you know you could
get slashed on the way to the comedy
show you better kill
[Laughter]
you better make it work you have a lot
of attention you better make it work if
it's
safe and you and your friends are like
skipping down the street you don't you
don't ever feel that
you know pressure where's that other
song right
pressure is good yeah and and i think
that now you're gonna get it you know
[Applause]
you